sí es una nueva batalla jurídica que
pierde el gobierno británico que
seguramente será apelada Pero como lo
mencionas Tiene un gran impacto en la
gobernabilidad del propio Primer
Ministro quien ha prometido
personalmente que acabará con la llegada
de embarcaciones pequeñas barcos
pequeños con inmigrantes ilegales casi
que todos los días a través del Canal de
la Mancha esta política Ruanda consiste
en que los inmigrantes ilegales que son
elegibles para solicitar el asilo en el
Reino Unido sean enviados a ese país
africano mientras se procesa su
solicitud los que no serán enviados a
sus países de origen el gobierno de
exhibido razones económicas como que
mantener el pago de las habitaciones en
las que están estas miles de personas
aquí en el Reino Unido le está costando
a las finanzas del Estado casi y más que
seis millones de libras esterlinas al
día lo que está ya teniendo un impacto
en las finanzas públicas pues hoy el
tribu de apelaciones de Londres ha dicho
que Ruanda no es un país seguro para que
estas personas sean enviadas y esta no
es la primera vez que la justicia se
interpone los planes del gobierno hace
exactamente un año en junio de 2022 la
justicia frenó un vuelo que casi
literalmente estaba despegando con
destino a Ruanda pero tampoco es un
asunto blanco y negro para la justicia
porque en diciembre de 2022 dos jueces
estaban a favor de esta decisión del
gobierno Así que Seguiremos viendo
decisiones judiciales a lo largo del año